stargate has been trending on twitter
the last few days but what does it mean
welcome to sidetrack your scifi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
so yeah
a tv show that hasn't been on our
screens for 11 years
has been trending on twitter and i've
had several messages ask me what does it
mean does this mean we're getting
stargate back on our screen soon that
amazon mgm are about to make an
announcement
well i actually did do a video yesterday
on the sidetrack sides um channel i'm
just giving you again an update on where
we're at with stargate and nothing has
really changed as far as i know from the
sources that i speak to
they have taken stargate out of review
they are now trying to decide what to do
with the show at the moment that is
pause and everything because they don't
know whether to go with brad wright's
pilot or to go with something new
so that is what's causing the problem
there's also an added fun that mgm is
actually as a company who's a lot more
of a mess apparently than amazon thought
and it's meant that they've had to
review all of their products all of
their projects
going over a lot of accounts and things
and that's also slowed things up
but what does it mean but it's been
trending on twitter does that mean that
we are going to get an announcement soon
well as i say unfortunately not it
probably doesn't but what it does mean
is there is a lot of people out there
like me and like you that love stargate
there are a lot of projects out there
like the twitter storm that we're
planning on july 27th i've got my
t-shirt on if you might see hashtag
target there are also lots of other
stuff projects like the twitter bring
back stargate we want stargate brad
stargate there's the hashtag 365 days of
stargate project basically you don't
have to go very far on twitter
particularly if you search for stargate
until you find lots of people out there
that absolutely adore this tv show and
that are desperate for it to come back
some desperate for brad to be at the
helm some not so bothered so it's
trending on twitter unfortunately it
doesn't really mean much other than what
we already knew that there are a lot of
people out there that absolutely adore
this show and that they are desperate
for it to return
so as i've told you in the last couple
of videos what's holding up stargate
getting greenlit is amazon trying to
make its mind of what to do with the
franchise whether to go with brad
wright's pilot that he wrote nearly
three years ago and whether to let brad
wright then steer the ship and become
captain of the new franchise or whether
to go in a completely different
direction with a completely new team
so
i wanted to get your opinion i put a
poll up on the community page and it's
only been up a couple of hours but
basically i said look when stargate
comes back is it brad right or nothing
you know if brad wright isn't in this
project i don't want it
or is it we just want stargate now it
doesn't matter if it's brad right or not
or do we want to wait and make sure that
the project is done properly that it's
thought through brad right or not
at the moment 75 of people saying that
they would rather be patient that they
would rather wait for the show to be put
together properly and that seems to be
what amazon are doing at the moment they
are actually taking a pause they're
thinking about how to do it they don't
just want to go head first into a
project that mgm has set up they want to
actually have a think about what is best
for the show in the long term i hope
they're actually probably if i'm being a
bit cynical thinking about how to make
the most money out of it but you know
let's pretend that these people actually
care about creating a good product
about 20 18 of people are saying spread
right or nothing now i'm not surprised
by that a lot of the comments i get
actually are that it's this is brad
wright's baby what is the point of
having a tv show named stargate without
brad right at the helm
i
i'm in two minds about that i totally
agree with him if you want somebody that
knows the show then obviously you go
with the creator but i'm also not the
biggest fan of sgu i know that's a bit
of a marmite tv show people either love
or hate it i don't hate it but um
it's you know it's not my favorite of
the three i felt i thought they went
completely the wrong way brad wright and
joseph malozzi obviously were the
creators of that and i don't necessarily
100 forgive them for it
so
i just wonder whether a new team
anybody that loves the franchise that's
the main thing if they hire somebody to
hold you know to steer this ship it's
got to be somebody that loves the show
as much as we do
um it can't just be a good filmmaker
it's got to be a good filmmaker that
loves star game
i wouldn't mind if they brought brad
right back isn't like a manager like a
kevin feige in the marvel movies you
know like in that universe you know
somebody that manages things who watches
over it you know make sure it's looked
after but bringing a whole new scheme of
writers executive producers all this
sort of thing and create a whole new
team around brad
who then just manages the project i'd be
fine with that but tell me what you
think get into the comments
what do you think about it trended on
twitter it is an interesting time i
personally just say that just shows how
many people are out there talking about
it and the frustration that we've been
waiting this long and that we really did
expect an announcement much quicker than
this once the amazon sale went through
because i have actually said to you
before that i think brad wright has been
playing a bit of a game he has been
going on his companion app and talking
about stargate as much as he possibly
can he's done two of those ai scripts
with amanda tapping and daniel and
everybody and even uh richard dean
anderson in the last one he has been
making sure that the fans do not forget
who created this show
i think he might have been doing that on
purpose and to be fair if he has been
he's a genius because
the rumors of him being maybe not taken
forward to the new show have been rife
for well over a year
so tell me exactly what you think in the
comments if you are new to the channel
please like subscribe hit the bell
notification it really helps us out also
you can go to cydashtrek.com and get
marvelous merchandise like the t-shirt
i'm wearing now also if you enjoy the
content please consider becoming a fully
fledged sidetracker and hit that join
button
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time
[Music]